TVs are still a part of e fo but  revenues in this segment are down as  more and more people watch their  favorite shows on mobile devices in high  definition of course premium the Sony z5  premium is the first smartphone to offer  the latest 4k standard more than 1600  exhibitors crowd the floor at this  year's Aoife the fair that used to be  focused on radio and TV is now showing  off items such as waterproof bluetooth  speakers and smartwatches like this  model by Lenovo with improved processing  power and battery life the wearable  technology sector is expected to almost  triple in the next five years a strong  start for a brand new category of  products another focus at this year's  fair is the smart home where household  appliances are connected via the  internet fridges stove tops and  dishwashers are controlled by smartphone  and even the washing machine is online